buitenlands
[Muziek]
welkom bij actieve livestream nummer
50.0
het is 17 oktober 2022 en we
beginnen de serie over interoceptie als
modellering van allostase als controle
welkom bij het actieve inferentie-
instituut we zijn een participatief online-
instituut dat communiceert over leren
en  toegepaste actieve gevolgtrekking oefenen
dit wordt opgenomen in een archief
livestream dus geef ons alstublieft
feedback zodat we ons werk kunnen verbeteren
alle achtergronden en perspectieven zijn
welkom en zullen goede video-
etiquette voor livestreams volgen
vandaag in 50.0 we beginnen deze serie
bespreken  de onderschepping van het papier als
modellering van allostase als controle
de auteurs zijn Eli synesh Jordan
therialt Dana Brooks John wilheim Von
DeMint Lisa Feldman Barrett en Karen's
Quigley
het is een paper gepubliceerd in het tijdschrift
biologische psychologie in januari 2022
en dit is slechts een inleiding en
context  video als decaan hier en ik
werken aan dit document en bespreken enkele
gerelateerde onderwerpen die
we hebben  ga enkele grote
vragen bespreken, de basisdoelen en abstracte
routekaart van het papier, ga dan in
op een paar belangrijke punten en
afbeeldingen en thema's en
kijk er dan vooral naar uit om het te bespreken met
auteurs of iemand anders die dat zou willen  om
mee te doen in de komende
weken oke dus ik ben Daniel Ik ben een onderzoeker
in Californië en
de paper werd geselecteerd door gedecentraliseerde
upvote
het was uh leuk om te lezen en het brengt een aantal
nieuwe onderwerpen in ons regime van aandacht,
dus ik ben op zoek  stuur dit door en ik geef het
door aan Dean,
bedankt Charlie Ik ben decaan Ik ben hier in
Calgary
Ik denk wat interessant is aan elk
papier dat naar schijnbaar discrete
dingen trekt en wat proximaal plaatst en
ze in de war brengt en ze dan
weer uit elkaar trekt  en probeert te kijken naar
wat er gebeurt als dingen worden gecombineerd, is
altijd iets waar ik altijd in geïnteresseerd ben,
in feite was het de
titel hiervan en het feit dat
ze allostase en
teresceptie bij elkaar brachten en wat
Dat gemiddelde was de reden waarom ik hier
wat tijd aan besteedde en
ik ben echt heel benieuwd naar wat de
auteurs te zeggen hebben nu ze
dit idee
goed hebben uitgevoerd, hoe zou je de grote
vraag
goed omschrijven?  bedoel, ik denk dat de focus hier ligt
op wat er gebeurt en wat we kunnen zeggen
over de vereisten van de controller die nodig
zijn om fysiologische taken uit te voeren, in verschillende
mate van complexiteit.
Ik ben er nooit echt zeker van geweest hoe de
specificiteit van verschillende uitkomsten en
gedragingen er in totaal uitziet, maar  Ik denk dat
een van de dingen die we kunnen zeggen, is dat als
er een voorspellende component is en
er een feedbackcomponent is
en ze zich concentreren op twee specifieke
soorten daarvan.
een beetje niet
verdwalen in het onkruid van nou dit gebeurde
hier en toen gebeurde dat daar maar
gewoon op dat algemene niveau wat voor
soort dingen als die twee dingen
worden samengevoegd
um moeten we zeggen als een bepaald patroon of
gemeenschappelijkheid
leuk Ik ben het ermee eens dat ik het in de
categorie van de vraag zou plaatsen hoe een bepaald systeem
onafhankelijk is
of modaliteitonafhankelijke fenomenen zoals
allostasis, wat anticiperende veranderingen
in de fysiologie is en verband houdt met een domein
of een use-case zoals onderschepping  en het
lijkt erop dat veel van de modellen die
we hebben onderzocht visueel of
conceptueel of symbolisch waren
en de interceptieve modaliteit is keer
op keer naar voren gekomen in discussies en dus is
dit een coole gelegenheid om naar
enkele formalismen voor onderschepping te kijken.
Oké, hier is  het artikel
zoals eerder beschreven slechts enkele van de
hoogtepunten die door de
auteurs op de
publicatiepagina zijn geschreven
onderschepping stelt de hersenen in staat om te
anticiperen op de opkomende metabole
behoeften van het lichaam onderschepping biedt
prestatiestatistieken voor de motorische regulatie van de ingewanden
we verbinden controletheorie met
besluitvorming en motorische controle  van het lichaam
modelleren we allostatische controle als optimale
controle met de tijdsvariatie  bij het referentiesignaal
praten ze over enkele
beperkingen van eerdere modellen en enkele
unieke aspecten van wat hun model doet
en de manier waarop ze het apic-model formuleren
iets toe te voegen
nee ik denk dat hun doelen duidelijk zijn
oke op claim dus Dean en ik
waren aan het
nadenken  van onszelf
in termen van schade-experts, taxateurs,
examinatoren en onderzoekers,
terwijl we
een hele handvol echt
belangrijke en opvallende
binnen het argument van dit relatief
lange
en technisch onderbouwde document tevoorschijn
haalden en een heleboel claims tevoorschijn haalden die
zijn geschreven die de punten met elkaar verbinden
enkele van de relevante uh-
interpretaties voor de formalismen
wil je een van hen benadrukken of
het is prima om ze gewoon te hebben
voor iedereen die hier van af wil,
maar ik zal dit zeggen hier is
er een, denk ik, een parallel die probeert te
worden getrokken  hier tussen
voorspellend
voorspellend uh verwerken nee ik zeg niet
dat voorspellend verwerken maar
verwerken als een voorspellend apparaat
en gevoelens
en controle en feedback en dus denk ik dat
er veel beweringen kunnen worden
gedaan,
maar dat is een heel erg
genuanceerde en ook een heel erg
complexe
ruimte om in te spelen en dus kan ik
begrijpen
waarom er heel veel is  beweert
um opnieuw of en hoe ver die
claims kunnen gaan voordat ze kapot gaan,
zal een interessant ding zijn om
met de auteurs te praten
ja, goed gezegd, het is een zeer verweven
gebied misschien is dat waar je naar wijst
als je zegt complex werken
ja  Ik heb veel haar, dus het is
lastig voor mij.
Oké,
abstract,
oké, ik zal de eerste drie lezen.
Het brein regelt het lichaam door te
anticiperen op zijn behoeften en te proberen
eraan te voldoen voordat ze ontstaan. Een proces
genaamd allostasis
allostasis vereist een model van de
veranderende sensorische omstandigheden in het
lichaam een ​​proces dat interceptie wordt genoemd in
dit artikel we onderzoeken hoe interoceptie
prestatiefeedback kan leveren voor allostase
we raden aan om allostase te bestuderen in de  rms
of control theory beoordeling van toepassingen van controletheorieën
op verwante kwesties
in de fysiologie motorische controle en besluitvorming
we synthetiseren deze door ze te relateren aan
de belangrijke eigenschappen van outostatische
regulatie als een controleprobleem we
schetsen vervolgens een normaal formalisme voor hoe de
hersenen allostatische controle
van  de ingewanden naar analogie twee
skeletmotorische controle inclusief een wiskundig beeld
en hoe intersectie fungeert als
prestatiefeedback voor allostase
tenslotte stellen we manieren voor om
implicaties van onze hypothese te testen
oke op het
stappenplan begint met een inleiding tot de
functie
van de hersenen in het lichaam
en dan  introduceert enkele van de belangrijkste
pijlers of fundamenten van hun
synthese en interpretatie
, namelijk de
theorie van interceptiecontrole als een benadering voor het
verenigen van de besluitvorming over motorische controle in de fysiologie
en allostase als een traject dat
stochastische optimale controle volgt.
Het vijfde deel is een discussie en
dan is er een appendix B en  C
a  en in hun woorden verbinden vier secties in dit
artikel onderschepping met allostase
sectie twee stelt vast hoe
interoceptie de hersenen in staat stelt
de fysiologische efficiëntie van
het lichaam in het huidige moment in te schatten,
wat precies is wat het moet weten
om actie te evalueren en te verfijnen
Sectie 3 introduceert controle  theorie
sectie 4 past de principes van de
controletheorie toe om een ​​nieuw formaatmodel af te leiden
van hoe de hersenen
de wenselijkheid van fysiologische
trajecten kunnen inschatten en
uiteindelijk toekomstige regelgevende beslissingen kunnen nemen. In sectie 5
worden de vorige drie secties samengevat
om de directe implicaties van het voorgestelde formalisme te onderzoeken.
biedt een verklarende woordenlijst, maar deze is
naar boven verplaatst en het is niet langer een appendix,
dus er is geen appendix een
appendix B1 biedt wiskundige
details met betrekking tot sectie 3 en
appendix C1 biedt wiskundige
details met betrekking tot sectie 4.
de sleutelwoorden waren onderschepping
allostase en voorspellende verwerking
we  ga je  om veel te praten over
onderschepping en allostase
enigszins in deze punt nul maar zeker
in de komende discussies en voor
voorspellende verwerking een goede recente
stream is live stream nummer 43 met
Maria
oke ook alleen ter referentie we zullen
hier net lang genoeg voor je pauzeren  om er een
screenshot van te maken als je wilt, is
er een nomenclatuurtabel
met de definitie van veel woorden, dus
hier zijn de eerste nomenclatuurtermen 1
tot en met 25.
en dan is hier de tweede helft van de
nomenclatuur 26 tot 49.
sorteer het alfabetisch
alles om toe te voegen aan de nomenclatuur
anders dan  om te zeggen dat
het goed is dat ze het hebben verstrekt en
dat het in de komende secties zal worden gebruikt.
Nou, ik denk dat het interessant is dat je
erop wees dat ze
de definities naar voren hebben gehaald en dan
als je naar de formalismen kijkt en dus denk
ik  vanuit het standpunt van
wat ze hierover willen zeggen, vereist
dit
vlechtwerk dat we op zijn minst een
gezond verstand hebben over wat dingen eerder
betekenen  we beginnen
te proberen uit elkaar te halen wat ze gelijk zijn,
dus ja ik vind het een beetje zoals dat
goed
gezegd oke deel één introductie de
functies van de hersenen in het lichaam
oke
er is een suggestief begin van deze
paper
um een ​​simpel spelletje trefbal spelen
dan  vereist dat je hersenen
de systemen van je lichaam voortdurend coördineren
en dit motief van trefbal zal
weer
terugkeren
en aan de linkerkant is een knuffelend gezicht
implementatie van een stabiel diffusie-
algoritme De prompt van de afbeelding was
DodgeBall speelse mieren actieve gevolgtrekking
gratis energieprincipe
en terwijl we de dia's aan het maken
waren, waren we bezig met actieve gevolgtrekkingen met
sommige van deze
beeldgenererende voorzieningen en dat wat goed te
doen
Ik denk dat het echt interessant is
dat dit wat de generator zei
dit het resultaat zou zijn van een
gecoördineerde
um
wat is  woord Ik ben op zoek naar
verstrengeling van deze van deze aanwijzingen,
maar heb niets gezegd over welke
strategie elk van  die
um Silhouettes gebruikt nu
en ik denk dat er een impliciet
gevoel is dat er ook een strategie aan de hand is
, dus nogmaals, als je een aantal van
deze echt interessante dingen samenbrengt
, denk ik dat het afhangt van hoe diep je
wilt gaan hoeveel  je wilt
de ruimte dimensioneren
dus wat is dat precies daar ja dit is
dezelfde prompt dit was gewoon een
andere deze komt meer een beetje meer
fotorealistisch
een beetje meer
ongrijpbaar je weet dat ze trefbal spelen
ja
zijn ze gewoon in orde
volgende sleutelwoord je kunt ervoor gaan
als je gewoon mensen de
definitie hier kan lezen, maar geef je eigen mening
wat onderschepping is
, ik denk dat er aan het eind van de
dag een bepaalde hoeveelheid
signaleringssignalering aan de gang is waarvan we ons
bewust worden  van soms jonge mensen
of alle mensen categoriseren
ze allemaal onder de paraplu van gevoelens
en uh
ik pakte dit van tots On Target alleen
omdat ik altijd in t werkte  wat een
ruimte van hoe houden we dit zo eenvoudig
mogelijk en dus als je deze
signalen krijgt, komen deze zintuiglijke signalen
van binnenuit het lichaam, dit zijn de
gevoelens die je krijgt en uh of
je ze verbindt met de wereld buiten
je
huid of je marges
eh soms doe je dat soms niet
je wordt gewoon wakker met buikpijn
dus wat betekent dat over vandaag
leuk
ik zou zeggen een beetje eng
onderschepping verwijst naar een
observatie en gevolgtrekking over verborgen
staten
met een referent  dat is in Tarot
in het lichaam in tegenstelling tot X-tarot
buiten het lichaam, maar er is waarschijnlijk
ook veel zoals vervaging en wat
het netvlies echt doet, doet het
gevolgtrekkingen over zichzelf en waar doet het
eigenlijk gevolgtrekkingen over de structuur van de buitenwereld
juiste interceptieve
interne modellen je hebt wat afbeeldingen toegevoegd, dus
wat zijn ze,
dus ik zal dit heel snel lezen, zodat
psychologen verwijzen naar de interne mod
inclusief onderschepping met veel termen en
Ik denk dat dat belangrijk is,
omdat er niet altijd
overeenstemming is geweest over het duidelijk definiëren van wat een
intern model is.
Dingen als onbewuste interesse
lijken te passen in deze overkoepelende belichaamde
simulatie Concepten en categorieën
gecontroleerde hallucinatie die nieuw
voor me was omdat ik dat niet doe  ik weet niet wat
dat betekent uh en ongeacht hoe
het wordt genoemd, wordt verondersteld dat het brein
een dynamisch model van zijn lichaam in
de wereld construeert. In dit artikel gebruiken we de termen
voorspellingssimulatie en concept en dus
voor iemand met een soort van mijn diepgaande
onderzoeksachtergrond  in termen van
ontvoering het signaal het interpreteerde
het object
um wat is dat model hoe kunnen
we voorkomen dat we in een ander groot
debat terechtkomen over of dat
representatief is en inhoud gevuld of
niet of is er iets dat
we
voelen Van binnenuit elke elke elke
eenmalige gegevens komen naar ons toe en
worden
op onze verschillende sensorische oppervlakken gegoten
buitenkant buitenkant aan de buitenkant
Ik denk dat er een
stukje van buiten komt Ik weet wanneer de
temperatuur in de kamer stijgt, maar mijn
temperatuur kan ook stijgen
omdat ik een slechte garnaal heb gegeten en het is
soms moeilijk om erachter te komen
of het komt omdat de hitte
weg is  omhoog of dat mijn lichaam reageert
met een opruiend
gebaar
ja dat is een
mooi punt zoals soms een
verschil wordt genoemd oorzaak maken of verschil maken
dat een verschil maakt veroorzaakt een virale
infectie dat de lichaamstemperatuur
stijgt
en of in hoeverre kan dat worden
ontleed in factoren van  het virus
versus dit de dynamiek verandert van het
immuunsysteem
zo
interessant beeld links weet ik
niet kan zeggen of het beeld links
door het beeld links wat is de
snelheid het beeld rechts beweegt eigenlijk
op de weg en  dat is een beetje
waarom ik de ambiguïteit daar wilde hebben
voor een enteroceptormodel, omdat je
weet dat demacio veel praat over
wat we echt kunnen
beschrijven en nastreven pr  korte termen en
wat enigszins dubbelzinnig blijft en de
auteurs in dit artikel praten ook een beetje
over God ja, als de
referent extern is, is het objectief dan is er
de mogelijkheid voor meerdere externe
perspectieven om op één lijn te komen, niet eens zeggend
dat dat beter is, maar gewoon de mogelijkheid
om te overwegen dat  als het belichaamde gedrag van
uw fysiologische instelpunt voor een of andere
fysiologische regulatie
wordt gewijzigd, heeft het niet dezelfde
mogelijkheid voor externe afstemming
ten goede en ten kwade
en bijna altijd met moeite om te
communiceren of soms ook te meten in
laboratoriumomgevingen en citaatcontrole
Dus  het zal interessant zijn om met auteurs hierover te praten en waarom
ze deze modaliteit bestuderen,
want voor de
computationele of
systeemonafhankelijke fenomenen die
ze gaan proberen te integreren
met Alice, is
allostasis zij definiëren deze term als
allostasis anticiperen  veranderende
behoeften prioriteiten evalueren en
de organisatie voorbereiden  sm om ze te bevredigen voordat ze
tot fouten leiden een proces genaamd
allostasis, dus laten we zeggen dat
je een allostatisch model hebt van de
temperatuur in de kamer
en de kerntemperatuur van het lichaam verandert niet
, dus kan iemand terugkijken en zeggen
dat dit niet het geval was  veranderen omdat er werd verwacht
dat het zou veranderen
en iemand zal gewoon zeggen hoe weet
je dat het toen werkte omdat het
de lichaamstemperatuur niet verhoogde
Ik concentreerde me op het feit dat
ze het beschrijven als een driedelig proces,
dus ik  altijd praten over wat
hier het minimum is wat is het minimum hier
hebben we nodig om dit te kunnen
doen Ik vind dat eigenlijk niet echt
interessant
waarom drie
niet vier of vijf het
in kleinere plakjes verdelen dat is er weer zo
een  vragen Ik zou graag
met de auteurs willen praten over
de juiste actieve gevolgtrekkingen die
ze schreven voordat ze
in formele modelleringsdetails duiken,
hieronder komen we later
in de
krant aan.  vergelijk en
contrasteer de benadering hier
apic met het prominente modelleringskader
actieve gevolgtrekking en we gaan
terug naar enkele van deze details en ik weet
zeker dat er veel discussie over is, maar
je maakte een heel interessant punt in
onze voorbereiding over hoe  ze
behandelen hun model niet als
stroomafwaarts of een uitvloeisel van enige
toewijding aan een bepaalde fysica
, zoals we vaak horen over het principe van vrije energie
, in feite mechanica,
maar ze behandelen
het
model eerder als een constructie van de eerste orde,
alles wat je wilt toevoegen  dat omdat
ik dacht dat dat echt was, me helpen om
te bepalen waar het papier over ging
ja dat is het straatgedeelte Ik denk dat
de werkbullet, in tegenstelling tot de meeste actieve interessemodellen
in de literatuur, het
onderstaande materiaal beschouwt als een onbepaalde
tijd of oneindig Horizon-besturingsinstelling
is interessant omdat  dat maakt het
echt heel duidelijk tussen waar ze
het over hebben en wat we vaak zien in
veel van de representaties, wat t0 is
T1 tot T
wat het ook
is om erachter te komen
wat er achtereenvolgens aan de hand is,
dus goed cool.
Dit gedeelte in de inleiding gaat
over enkele problemen met andere modellen,
ze praten over hoe bestaande modellen van
onderschepping ofwel allostase hebben geformuleerd
als een prospectieve
beslissing-  problemen maken
zonder na te denken over hoe deze beslissingen
worden uitgevoerd, wat een heleboel
verschillende interpretaties heeft, maar
misschien vereist het opsommen van
beleid en vervolgens de selectie uit
beleid
of als een motorische controleprobleem zonder te
overwegen waar motorische commando's vandaan komen
een ander probleem dat ze hebben met andere
modellen in plaats van metabole
efficiëntie als het doel te behandelen ze bespreken
homeostase de regulatie van lichaamsvariabelen
om setpoints vast te stellen met een vaste
tolerantie voor fouten,
dus dit wordt echt een cool
thema dat is in
plaats van het setpoint en de
variabiliteit vast te stellen
zie die uitkomst als  te wijten zijn aan een
ander proces dat wel resulteert in een
aantrekking  een set of punt kiezen met een vast
instelpunt en een empirische tolerantie voor
fouten, evenals misschien enkele punten van geen
terugkeer enzovoort,
maar al die resultaten zien als de
realisatie van een dynamisch systeem dat
eigenlijk geen instelpunt nastreeft, maar
eerder  een helling nastreeft op een grafiek die
we zullen onderzoeken en dat eenzelfde zone van
maximale beheersbaarheid
en vermindering van verrassing rond de
zone van maximale beheersbaarheid
over de evolutionaire tijd geassocieerd zal worden
met dit soort overlevingsvariabele
en enkele andere punten oke al het andere
nou, het is relatie relatie
relatie en dan zeggen ze dat dit
artikel deze kloof wil opvullen.
praten over targeting
Ik denk aan het feit dat ze de
relatie zien als een
soort sleutelrol in wat ze denken dat
hier gebeurt,
um betekent dat  dat ze misschien de kloof
um blijft ik bedoel, ze zijn
hier dingen aan het plaatsen die we kunnen overwegen
en overwegen, maar ik weet niet zeker
of we echt een gat vullen waar
we gewoon een beetje begrijpen wat
hierin staat  spatie
rechts
sectie twee dus aan het begin van
sectie twee de bovenste
alinea's onderschepping modellering van het
lichaam inschatting van de efficiëntie en dan
de onder de vouw
sectie 2.5 de samenvatting dus zowel deze
pre als post 2.
um 2.0
2.2
bevat veel structurele informatie
over  de belangrijkste punten in dit artikel
iets om aan deze specifieke dia toe te voegen
of we gaan gewoon naar de secties met een
ster helemaal onderaan daar
willen mensen misschien iets over lezen
omdat ik denk dat dat is en dat wil zeggen
dat dat controversieel is, maar  Ik denk dat het
interessant is, ja,
dat de beweging naar het
responsieve bereik van een capaciteitscurve
mogelijk de noodzaak
van een speciaal neuraal circuit of module
die specifiek de
gedragsconstructies van het belonen van kosten,
dus wat betekent het
om over te gaan naar een
niet-beloningsgericht
begrip van fysiologie
of het herinterpreteren van beloning
oke paragraaf 2.1 introduceert een
onderscheid dat de sleutel zal zijn in
de rest van het artikel, namelijk het
verschil tussen twee typen  van viscerale
sensorische variabelen interceptief
die welke hoeveelheden
hulpbronnen vertegenwoordigen gereguleerde hulpbronnen en die
welke de snelheden vertegenwoordigen waarmee
processen werken gecontroleerde processen
gereguleerde hulpbronnen worden stabiel gehouden
relatief stabiel in de tijd voorbeelden
zijn onder meer bloedglucose en
kernlichaamstemperatuur,
dus van belang is dat ze dat niet hebben  om een
uitputbare hulpbron te zijn
de gereguleerde hulpbron is een soort van
de begrensde variabele in een fysiologie in
een homeostase context het is niet
noodzakelijkerwijs Een uitputtende zoals metaboliet
uh gereguleerde hulpbron zoals bloedglucose
of kernlichaamstemperatuur vertegenwoordigt een
fysieke hoeveelheid of een stof zoals
glucose de hoeveelheid ervan  kan niet onmiddellijk veranderen,
dus ik  denk dat het interessant zal zijn
om te vragen
wat verschillende uh gereguleerde bronnen
van verschillende modaliteiten zijn
en dan zijn gecontroleerde
processen de snelheden waarmee fysiologische
processen werken, dus in dat geval zou het
zijn als het soort input-
outputrelaties van bloedglucose
oke ja we praten gewoon  daar hebben we
het laatst over gehad dat is wat het
verschil is tussen gripper en gript en
kunnen beide tegelijk bestaan
mooi
2.2 terug naar het voorbeeld van de DodgeBall de
hartslag en de bloeddruk moeten
stijgen tijdens aerobics zoals
opgemerkt in het voorbeeld van de DodgeBall
dus er moet  enige fysiologische
aanpassing
zijn om te beginnen met trainen en door te
gaan met
trainen in rusttoestand de baroreceptor
die de drukreceptor is, de hartslagreflex
zou normaal gesproken elke stijging
van de bloeddruk tegengaan door de
hartslag te vertragen, maar bij inspanning moeten uw
bloeddruk en hartslag beide
toenemen om de  benodigde verhoging
van de bloedstroom vereist door uw
ex  het trainen van spieren
en dus is er een discussie over hoe
dit soort modulatie van reflex het mogelijk maakt
om een ​​hele functie te verschuiven
die een verandering in bloeddruk relateert aan een
verandering in je hartslag,
dus dit beschrijft als een dynamische
systeembenadering en fysiologisch model
voor  hoe de causale of
correlatiestructuur van verschillende fysiologische
variabelen vrij algemeen kan worden gemodelleerd,
maar het
wordt specifieker
ja een beetje covariatie daar
en uh
en fysiologie en weg gaan we
oke 2.2 voorspellen en modelleren van de
reeksen van gereguleerde en gecontroleerde
processen dit  beschrijft enkele van de
parameters
van
de curve
de drempel- en verzadigingspunten
die gedeeltelijk worden afgeleid Definieer curven die
zijn afgeleid van functies
die fysiologen gewoonlijk gebruiken
om het verband tussen
verstoringen en regulerende reacties te modelleren,
gewoonlijk responscurven of
overdrachtsfuncties noemend
en vervolgens de term capaciteit  krommen zullen
worden gebruikt om te benadrukken  e het feit dat hoewel
dergelijke curven in de loop van de tijd
op elk moment kunnen verschuiven, ze de
huidige reeks beperkte regelgevende
middelen vertegenwoordigen die beschikbaar zijn voor een organisme,
dus je zou je een financiële capaciteitscurve kunnen voorstellen
om
op een bepaald moment een bepaalde markt in stand te houden, zoals een soort van zoals
de diepte
maar naar
analogie
en dan is dit
idee om te modelleren hoe een systeem reageert
op verstoringen
niet noodzakelijkerwijs het modelleren van het
interne model van dat systeem, maar als
je een beter generatief model van het
verstoorde systeem bouwt dan de betere
experimenten en hoe verder je kunt  uh
heb een soort verstoring van het
systeem, het stelt je in staat om je systeem te benaderen
zonder een sterke hypothese over
de structuur ervan
de capaciteitscurve in figuur twee punt
of in figuur één heeft de wiskundige
vorm en dan wordt figuur één getoond
naast vergelijking één
de parameters zijn  definieerde de functie
y is uh nemend in U mu K zijnde R Big B
en deze te combineren in een vergelijking
het cijfer één op  de x-as toont
de bloeddruk
en vervolgens toont de y-as het
baseline-activeringspercentage van de
reflex die deze fysiologische variabele moduleert,
dus bij 100 is dat de
doelbloeddruk of een soort van wat
het homeostatische instelpunt zou worden genoemd omdat
het  lijkt een attractor te zijn
op dat moment vindt de baseline-activering van
de loopreflex plaats
als de bloeddruk stijgt, dan
activeert de loopreflex tot 2x
drempelwaarde bij 2x activering van de
baseline en vervolgens als de bloeddruk
daalt de loopreflex weer met
deze sigmoid  symmetrie neemt af
dat is een dynamisch model voor de regulering
van bloeddruk
vergelijkingen 2 3 en 4.
schets de vorm van een generatief model een
procedure voor het probabilistisch
voorspellen van waargenomen variabelen in termen
van niet-waargenomen variabelen
de vermelde variabelen zijn niet-waargenomen
variabelen die worden bemonsterd uit een A
Priory-waarschijnlijkheid  distributie niet
afhankelijk van gegevens,
dus dat verwijst naar het gebruik van een
generat  ive model en hoe deze vergelijkingen het
vormen
Het voorstel hier heeft een ongebruikelijk kenmerk
de vergelijkingen voor X de gemiddelde arteriële
bloeddruk en waarom de vatreflex
activatie als een percentage van Baseline
dus figuur 1 X en Y
of in termen van de kwantielvariabele U
de  kwantielvariabele geeft
uniform de relatie weer tussen de
bloeddruk en de
activering van de loopreflex, ongeacht veranderingen in
het werkpunt van de capaciteitscurve Punt mu
en gain K het kwantiel hangt alleen af ​​van
de functionele vorm van de capaciteitscurve
en niet van de parameters, dus we zullen
uitpakken  dat is iets technischer,
maar ze wijzen erop dat als een kenmerk van
hun model
hier opnieuw figuur één iets groter is
met meer ruimte om later te bespreken en
hier is figuur twee
, de capaciteitscurve van figuur
één in blauw met een gelineariseerde respons
in oranje
rond het werkpunt de Blue
Diamond-markering,
zodat
men dit kan zien als de maximale positieve
helling van deze sigmoïde curve
en  dat onder
de specificatie
dat de reflex
op een sigmoïdale
manier zal worden geactiveerd, afhankelijk van of men zich in
een opwaarts gebogen deel of een neerwaarts gebogen deel bevindt
of denkt dat het de
maximale positieve helling
nastreeft en vervolgens dat punt nastreeft en wordt
beloond  door bewegingen in de richting van maximale
manoeuvreerbaarheid en controle
zou het equivalent zijn van het nastreven van een
homeostatisch model waarbij dit een
vast punt-attractor is,
zodat het soort bodem van de
kom
in deze oranje lijn wordt gemaximaliseerd in
helling in plaats van dat de blauwe diamant wordt
verkleind  de afstand van 100.
goed,
ik denk dat we dit
gedeelte twee keer hebben gekopieerd,
het was zo ongebruikelijk dat we het twee keer hebben gekopieerd
ja 2.3 keer
terug naar het voorbeeld van de DodgeBall
en ze gaan hun reikwijdte uitbreiden
Voorbij alleen de Barrow-reflex bloeddruk
naar circulerende niveaus van zuurstofglucose
en koolstofdioxide,
daarna richten we ons op bloedglucose als een
gereguleerde hulpbron met glucagon als het
gecontroleerde proces dat de afscheiding van
glucose in het bloed en insuline als
het controleproces waardoor
glucose uit het bloed kan worden verwijderd, dus de
loopreflex was als een enkele volumeknop
of een triage-verpleegkundige die
de enkele respons kan verlagen of verhogen, dus als een
fysiologische variabele hoog is, is het alsof
het kan  alsof verwijderde
glucoseregulatie meerdere hormonen
heeft, het zal zijn als gebufferd van twee
verschillende kanten op een iets andere
manier, maar met veel van dezelfde
formalismen en logica
om een ​​iets
ander en complexer fysiologisch
systeem te introduceren
okee
um de sectie bespreekt enkele bevindingen
dat de bloedglucosespiegels niet
actief worden verdedigd op een biologisch
hardgecodeerd instelpunt, net
zomin als de hartslag in plaats daarvan glucagon en insuline twee
hormonen zijn
die elkaars effecten in evenwicht
brengen om de bloedglucose tot een punt
binnen het bezinkingsbereik te brengen,
waarbij glucose de  bloed nadat
de persoon voedsel en glucose heeft ingenomen en
vervolgens van het bloed naar een ander
lichaam gaat  weefsels om hun functie te ondersteunen
alles om toe te voegen aan deze
dia, niet specifiek, wacht nu tot
we aan het einde van sectie komen de tweede
twee dingen
dus hier is figuur drie
ze schrijven figuur drie
toont grafieken van de resulterende functies
van deze vergelijking
toegepast op  het geval van insuline
dat kan worden geïnterpreteerd als capaciteitscurves
oranje sigmoïde is insuline
de blauwe sigmoïde is glucagon
ze hebben verschillende hormoonspiegels op
verschillende x-as, dit is het
glucosegehalte in het bloed en dus zie je een
soort bekend gedrag als de glucose
hoog is  dan heeft insuline een hoge secretie
die de absorptie van glucose stimuleert
en wanneer glucose laag wordt, in dit geval
onder de 2,5 of 3 of zo, dan wordt
glucagon uitgescheiden om glucose op te wekken
om in het bloed te komen
oke
en dus kan men zich voorstellen dat de
glucosespiegel zal oscilleren  in deze ruimte,
maar niet precies
ingesteld
op een instelpunt met een residu dat wordt
geminimaliseerd,
sectie 2.4
is waar ze afstappen van het bespreken van dit
soort regelgevende mo  del
uh in haalbare reeksen en capaciteiten
zou een modulair beloningssysteem kunnen ondervangen
hier is een argument of beroep op
neuroanatomie er is geen enkele
hersensite die specifiek codeert voor
appetijtelijke of aversieve
versterkingswaarde het is nuttig om discrete
belonings- en beslissingssystemen te herkaderen als domein
Algemene allostatische controlesystemen
de  domein algemeenheid van onderschepping
biedt verdere theoretische ondersteuning voor
het idee dat we geen
mentale modules of faculteitspsychologie nodig hebben Concepten
om te begrijpen hoe een brein werkt
een wiskundig verantwoord en biologisch
plausibel verslag van allostatische controle
vereist geen modulair of afzonderlijk
beloningssysteem in de centrale  zenuwstelsel
en een beetje meer over dit onderwerp iets toe te
voegen
nu laten we naar 37 gaan.
oke de beloningen van controle dus hier
wilde ik twee artikelen benadrukken met een
aantal mooie afbeeldingen
van beide artikelen waarbij Tobias Norville betrokken was
en deze artikelen worden geciteerd in de krant
ter discussie en ze tonen allemaal
behoorlijk wat inte  rustfuncties, dus om
enkele van deze
grafieken te markeren, hier zijn bewegingen binnen een glucose-
en temperatuurruimte, dus de regulering van
meerdere fysiologische variabelen
hier linksonder is de
integratie van het homeostatische instelpunt voor onderschepping
en motorische commando's zoals
gerelateerd aan foerageren
hier zijn enkele Bayesiaanse
visualisaties met  een eerdere
onwaarschijnlijkheid en over deze
tweerichtingsrelatie van gevolgtrekking en een voormalig
dynamisch model het verhaal van twee
dichtheden en dan de laatste dit is uh
een andere benadering van glucosemodellering voor lichaamstemperatuur
die op dat idee komt dat we
beschrijven als naar de bodem gaan  van de
schaal
waar de vorm van dit
servet
kan worden ontworpen, ontwikkeld of geselecteerd,
zodat het marmer het grootste deel van zijn
tijd in een bepaalde zone doorbrengt en dit is
slechts een andere manier om over
dit soort aantrekkingssystemen na te denken in
plaats van als gelijke sporen  of zo verder
oke alles om toe te
voegen, ik denk dat sectie twee in feite
bevestigt dat als je gaat t
o elke vorm van voorspellende prestatie doen
die een element van continuïteit
heeft dat afhangt van een soort
herkenbare eindige limieten en ook
variabiliteit binnen wat die limieten ook
zijn
en ik denk dat um een
beetje spreekt over het idee dat
er een in  een soort van twee-factor situatie
er is een signalering die er zo uitziet
en ze wezen op een paar
voorbeelden van de loopreflex en de
en het glucagon-ding en
ze probeerden ook te voorkomen dat ze te
simpel of te veel verminderden zoals
ze probeerden
de complexiteit van die twee voorbeelden
behouden in termen van wat ze
probeerden te handhaven is iets dat
ons in staat stelt om naar deze capaciteitscurves te gaan kijken
oke deel drie regeltheorie
de verenigende lens voor fysiologie motorische
controle en besluitvorming
en dan een  van hun samenvattingen van het
hoofdstuk introduceert deze sectie
Concepten uit de technische
regeltheorie en beoordeelt vervolgens de
toepassingen ervan in de Life Sciences the  se
omvatten fysiologie sectie 3.1 skelet
motorische beweging sectie 3.2 en
besluitvorming sectie 3.3 sectie 3.4 zal
toekomstige interceptieve toestanden verbinden met
huidige bewegingen.
Verhelderend wat allostatische regulatie energie-
efficiënter maakt dan homeostatische regulatie,
de volgende sectie 4 zal voortbouwen op het
relaas van controle gebruikt in de fysiologie  om te
suggereren hoe onderschepping allostase ondersteunt
oke hier gaan we niet alles lezen
op de slide maar dit komt uit
paragraaf 3.1 controle theorie voor
fysiologie een betrouwbaar een betrouwbaar lichaam
opgebouwd uit onbetrouwbare onderdelen alles wat hier aan
toe te voegen is
nee
mensen willen dit gewoon lezen  yep, ik zal
gewoon roepen dat een controller
goed presteert, deze moet een
soort kopie of spiegel van het verwachte gedrag van de plant bevatten,
wat een intern model
wordt genoemd, regeltheoretici genaamd assisteren het
aangedreven systeem om te planten en het gewenste
traject de referentie  traject
en er is een interessante discussie
over dit soort um
draad van regeltheorie
figuur vier
dus figuur vier is een functioneel
blokschema van een modelgebaseerd regelsysteem
de plant in Orange is het object of
systeem waarvan de beweging of ander gedrag wordt
gecontroleerd
de controller paars stuurt signalen
regelt stevige blokpijlen
de verandering hoe de plant beweegt  en
signaleert de verwachte uitkomstvoorspellingen
stevige gele pijl naar de
staatsschatter in het geel enzovoort mensen kunnen
de rest ervan lezen
voor deze cijfers Daniel als we
verder naar beneden in de dia's komen waarom lees ik niet
en dan kun je de cursor laten lopen
over de verschillende delen van het model zodat
mensen kunnen zien en in realtime kunnen zien
hoe de twee dingen op één lijn liggen, klinkt
goed, we zullen dat doen voor de toekomstige
en dit zal
die van onze eerdere discussies in
livestream intrekken of herinneren  23 vaardige prestaties en
interactionisme en instructie en
hoe te denken over motorplanten
enzovoort rechts
paragraaf 3.2 het lichaam bewegen de
referentiecontrolehypothese zodat de
referentiecontrolehypothese de
citaten waren naar Feldman 2015
en latash 2021
en de referentiecontrolehypothese
beschrijft het skeletmotorsysteem in
termen van een hiërarchie van controllers met controllers op een
hoger niveau in de hersenen
die referentietrajecten voorschrijven naar
de lagere reflexen in het ruggenmerg.
reflexen vergelijken vervolgens de
werkelijke lengte van de spier zoals gesignaleerd
door afferente proprioceptorneuronen met de
referentielengte die door de hersenen wordt verzonden
en trekken de spier samen om de
twee in overeenstemming te brengen en dus hier is het
bovenste deel van de inhoudsopgave van
Feldman's 2015-boek  referent controle van
actie en perceptie en de paper of
latash in physics of Life review 2021
met enkele afbeeldingen rond dit soort
benadering
buitenlands
je kunt beginnen met deze dia over de
echte wereld
oke nou ik zal alleen wijzen op een paar
dingen die de auteurs zeggen  omdat ze
niet willen worden beschuldigd van een soort van
overfitting hier
start je motorische controle  experiment is
slechts een beperkte overlap met de feitelijke
structuur van motorische controle, dus
slechts een beperkte overlap experiment op het
bereiken van gedrag houdt in dat een
onderzoeker de reikende
taak voorschrijft aan de deelnemers deelnemers het
brein functioneert niet specifiek om
instructies van een experimentator op te volgen,
maar om hun eigen lichaam te reguleren
de  daadwerkelijke organisatie van het centrale
zenuwstelsel verloopt beter met een
binnenstebuiten zicht op motorische functie
beweging van het lichaam I.E. de somateuze
somatomotorische paden overschrijding van de regulatie van
het lichaam, bijvoorbeeld in het spel met Dr-
waarde als je onverwachts op een hard
of scherp blok stapt of  object dat je normaal
gesproken niet met opzet doorboort als je erop bent
gestapt, dus ik wilde nu gewoon
door mijn voet gaan
omdat ik misschien mijn focus nog steeds ligt op het
stabiliseren van mijn houding zwaartekracht met spiraal
en pijn je voelt dat onderscheppend
en de ongeplande verstoring van elke
weefselbeschadiging vereist dat u een
beslissing neemt over wat u vervolgens moet doen  e
jezelf om je voet te verzorgen of
door die pijn te spelen
Ik denk dat het feit dat ze proberen te
beperken wat ze zeggen de mate
is waarin het doelstuk hiervan
als een goede zaak kan worden beschouwd,
omdat ik denk dat er een  een paar
gebieden in de
buurt,
dus wat is er in deze relatie tussen
een commandosysteem of een controlesysteem en
een vraagsysteem, waar doen dingen
zoals wanneer je lichaam
begint te lijden aan milde onderkoeling
en je weet dat mensen weten dat
je hersenen niet meer goed functioneren
eh hoe maak je onderscheid tussen bijvoorbeeld
eh ik krijg een Slurpee-hoofdpijn en
je legt de Slurpee neer en stopt met
drinken omdat je weet dat dat
het effect is versus je hebt je ledematen
waarvan je niet weet dat ze op
dit punt of op dat moment bevroren zijn  tenminste hopelijk niet voor
ons knop blijf bewegen zodat je
je niet tegenhoudt je vermijdt te stoppen met
bewegen allemaal samen wat in
wezen dood is dus hier hebben we een
vraag of je al dan niet
um w  zonder in het argument te komen
omdat het vrij duidelijk is dat als je
hersenen dood zijn, je dood bent, maar als je
handen dood zijn of en je
leeft nog dat duidelijke onderscheid tussen een
commandocentrumgevolg en een
vraagcentrumgevolg wat betekent dat
in termen  van oké, dus er
gebeuren dingen die je automatisch doet
om jezelf in leven te houden in een aantal van
de meest kritieke situaties en het is
niet zoals die van jou je
je hand heeft de hersenen en toch kan het
door gewoon rond te bewegen Voorbij een
reflexief ding zijn  in staat om je
lang genoeg in leven te houden totdat
iemand je te hulp komt als bijvoorbeeld,
dus ik weet niet of dat verwarrend is of
niet, maar ik denk dat er een
verzoening is, maar dat gaat tussen
commando en vraag en misschien wat
controle  is het vermogen om
gecommandeerde tijden op te geven zodat
een nieuwe reactie het overneemt en je in
leven houdt en je weet misschien niet per
se hoe je dat moet doen vanuit een
commandocentrum, dus we'  Ik zal daarover met de
auteurs moeten praten, want dit zijn
vragen die ik heb omdat ik een
beetje een fysiologische achtergrond heb, dus ik
vraag me af wat deze extreme situaties
zijn, oké
sectie 33 beslissingen nemen die
toekomstige referentietrajecten construeren
ze gebruiken het woord eisen, dus
we'  ik zal er later over praten ja meer
citaten van drie drie voor degenen die
een screenshot willen maken van
praten over ergoniciteit die ook naar voren komt
in bijlage B waar we ons niet op
gaan concentreren
oké je kunt figuur vijf lezen en ik
zal de muis gebruiken  uh dus een functioneel
blokschema voor een experiment experimenteel
psycholoog taakgericht beeld van motorische
controle het diagram toont een formele logische
structuur hier
op conceptueel niveau de kaders en
pijlen komen niet overeen met de anatomie van
de hersenen of het zenuwstelsel in tegenstelling
tot figuur vier  het diagram maakt
onderscheid tussen skeletmotorische
hersenen
en perifere
rekreflexcontrollers en tussen sensorische
staatsschatters hersenen en periferie  al
zintuigen sensorische oppervlakken sensorische oppervlakken
het diagram toont een technisch
perspectief
belangrijk om op te merken dat bij een psychologisch
experiment waarbij de onderzoeker
een taak voor gedrag voorschrijft aan
deelnemers, dus er is een uiterlijk
en het brein van een deelnemer fungeert dan als een
controlesysteem om het gedrag te bereiken
de voorgeschreven Gedragssystemen
die het lichaam in stand houden
dienen dus de systemen die het lichaam bewegen
die op hun beurt een voorgeschreven
Gedrag dienen dus opnieuw focussen op het
voorschrijvende de uiterlijkheid de
informatie komt
binnen goed
werking van laptop ja volgende
functioneel blokschema voor een controle
theoretische weergave  van allostasis in tegenstelling
tot figuur vijf dit diagram toont een
gesloten regelsysteem dat is ontworpen voor
autonome regulering van het lichaam en
het gewenste taakgedrag van de experimentator,
vervangen door of door sorry de
allostatische capaciteitsschatter
die voorspellingen verzendt van capaciteitscurven
waarnaar we al hebben gekeken
de binnenreceptie  ive State schatter
en ontvangt
voorspellingsfouten om zijn schattingen bij te werken
de bijgewerkte schattingen worden uitgegeven als een
referentiesignaal naar de motorcontroller van de bezoeker
dit diagram toont een formele
logische structuur een conceptueel niveau de
afgebeelde hypothese wordt beperkt door
de afgeleide anatomische structuren in
Bear 2017  maar de kaders en pijlen brengen
geen herhaling in kaart niet één op één in kaart brengen op de
anatomie van de hersenen of het zenuwstelsel
helemaal goed,
dus om het verschil hier te benadrukken is
de linkerkant bijna als een
onderwijskundige
Regelingen en dit is hoe de
experimenteel psycholoog  denkt aan
deze taak, dat is alsof we
de instructies opschrijven de pseudocode voor de
taak houd je hartslag binnen dit
bereik
en dan is er enige besluitvorming
met het Skeletor-motorsysteem, of het nu in
staat is tot bewuste actie
en strekken
of meer uh onderbewust
en dan door te handelen  fysiologie in
het lichaam of in de buitenwereld die
onderscheppen  ve toestandsschatter komt in
lijn met de gewenste
implementatie van de skeletmotorische
beslissing
in tegenstelling tot de rol van de
taakinstructies om zo te zeggen wordt
in deze controletheoretische weergave gesubstitueerd
met de allostatische capaciteitsschatter
als de imperatief en dat voedt zich
via een zeer vergelijkbare set  aan de
rechterkant, maar hier hebben we eigenlijk de
beslissingscontroller van de ingewandenmotor
in uh in tegenstelling tot een scalaire
motorbeslissingscontroller omdat deze meer
gericht is op het
kiezen van de linkerknop of de
rechterknop en figuur zes is meer gericht op
het soort vat  reflex
controle theorie, maar dat generaliseert ook meer
dan
oké Ik denk dat dit gewoon weer een ander beeld is
sectie vier allostasis als traject
volgen stochastische optimale controle
deze sectie zal ons formele
model van allostatische besluitvorming beschrijven de
allostatische pad integrale controle apic
model
apic heeft een eenvoudig idee op zijn  kern net
zo perceptueel Concepten dienen als interne
modellen van de bo  dy's sensorische oppervlakte-
actie Concepten dienen ook als interne
modellen van potentieel gedrag en hun
voorspelde resultaten.
Paragraaf 4.1 stuurt een SOC-
doelfunctie aan vanuit de wiskundige
vorm waarmee paragraaf 2
capaciteitscurven weergeeft,
vervolgens worden paragraaf 4.2, 4.3 en 4.4
beschreven, waardoor dit apic-model
alles wordt weggevaagd  voeg
nee toe, laten we daar heen gaan. 4.1
capaciteitscurves omzetten in
objectieve functies,
aangezien een bepaalde capaciteitscurve zoals
de 1 en figuur 1
hierboven een maximale waarde op de verticale
as is, deze kan worden gedeeld door de maximale y-
waarde om deze te normaliseren naar bereik  tussen 0
en 1. eenmaal op deze manier genormaliseerd
kan het worden geïnterpreteerd als een cumulatieve
verdelingsfunctie vanuit de kanstheorie.
Dit is precies wat
Srinivasan Laughlin en dubs
deden om het afvuren van retinale
neuronen en vliegen te interpreteren als een vorm van
voorspellende codering zie  daar cijfer een
de afgeleide van een CDF cumulatieve
verdelingsfunctie levert een
probabi  dichtheidsfunctie PDF
dus de afgeleide van een CDF geeft een PDF.
Dit is de meer bekende manier
om een ​​kansverdeling weer te geven
waarbij de hoogte op de verticale as
overeenkomt met de waarschijnlijkheid in de PDF,
maar voor een PDF die is afgeleid van een capaciteitscurve
geeft dit de relatieve
responsiviteit weer  tot verstoring zullen
we zo'n distributie een referentieverdeling noemen,
dus dit is een transformatie van
statistische distributies tussen de
PDF, wat de
kansdichtheidsfunctie en de CDF cumulatieve distributiefunctie
is.
hopelijk is dit nog steeds nuttig
om de relatie tussen de twee te overwegen,
dus hier aan de linkerkant van deze drie
afbeeldingen de PDF, wat de meer
bekende manier is om een
kansverdeling weer te geven, we zouden zeggen dat
dit een uniforme verdeling is, er is een
kans van één op zes om te krijgen  elke
uitkomst van een zeszijdige dobbelsteen
of in een situatie van ongeveer gaussiaanse klokkromme die
h beide van deze twee middelste
en rechter afbeeldingen tonen
de PDF van de belcurve is de
belcurve dus de PDF is de meest
bekende de uniforme verdeling is als een
platte lijn in de PDF de belcurve is
als een belcurve in de PDF
maar aangezien je de maximale en
minimale waarden kent,
al was het maar
asymptotisch, kun je een cumulatieve
verdelingsfunctie maken die in
principe zo laag begint als de functie kan gaan,
de ondersteuning voor die verdeling en het
accumuleert gewoon cumulatief,
dus het is handig om de vraag te beantwoorden
wat is  de kans
om een ​​vier of drie of twee of één te krijgen
die tweederde is of wat de
kans is om een ​​z-score van
minder dan twee te krijgen zoals twee standaarddeviaties
positief welk deel van de curve
onder die z-score op de PDF ligt  en dat
is aan te pakken door
snel een punt op deze CDF op te zoeken
, blijkt dat die relatie
tussen de PDF en de CDF die
meer vertrouwd is, zoals een
dobbelsteen gooien of evalueren zoals  hoogte in een
klaslokaal
kan worden gebruikt
op de capaciteitscurve die eerder is besproken
om naar een distributie te gaan die, wanneer
gemaximaliseerd, zich op deze
plek van maximale controle bevindt,
dus hier krijgt de CDF van figuur
2 de afgeleide en dan wordt het
de PDF
met uh dit soort negatief
curve vorm en dat is een soort van wat
werd gesuggereerd met deze Orange Line
wordt gemaximaliseerd Orange Line wordt
gemaximaliseerd
is het hoogtepunt op deze
bel curve zoals, maar het is geen klassieke
klittenband maar het is een berg, het is een
Peak waarvan je kunt weten aan welke kant  je bent
op en daarom vrij eenvoudig te optimaliseren
naar
um
voor analytisch gemak we nemen de
praktijk uit tedorov 2006 om een ​​logdichtheid te gebruiken
de logaritme van een PDF als een
objectieve functie in plaats van de PDF
zelf
het werkpunt blijft dan
verschijnen als lokaal maximum  terwijl de versterking
de kosten bepaalt van beweging weg
van het werkpunt en de waarde
van beweging ernaartoe, toont figuur 8
het objectieve functielogboek de  nsiteit die
overeenkomt met de originele Barrel-
reflex capaciteitscurve
figuur 9 verduidelijkt de
relatie tussen de verschillende vormen
van capaciteitscurve verder door ze alle drie
naast elkaar te tonen, dus dit is een heel
mooi figuur linksboven in de
figuur is de figuur met de reflex
die omhoog of omlaag wordt gebeld om
de bloeddruk te reguleren
die wanneer geïnterpreteerd als een CDF
kan resulteren in een PDF
en dat is een enkele piek die u kunt
maximaliseren in
plaats van te proberen een residu te berekenen
de vorm van deze curve wordt iets
mooier om rekenkundig te optimaliseren
als je het zo maakt dat het een
gladdere kom is in
plaats van een soort omgekeerde
trechtervorm
, kunnen we alleen meer in detail treden waarom ik denk
dat dat cool zal zijn waarom is deze logstap van
belang of maakt het uit, maar het volstaat om te
zeggen  dat dit de grote stap is waarmee
je de sigmoid-jongleeract kunt veranderen
in
de
bergbeklimtafel één vat een sleuteltabel samen
één vat enkele sleutelnotaties samen
we beweren niet dat ons grafische model
de anatomie van de hersenen nauwkeurig vastlegt,
het legt op referentie gebaseerde
sensorische motorische controle vast over een hiërarchie
van tijdschalen een enkele functie gedeeld
met een hersenvariabelen
in een tabel
vergelijkingen vijf en zes over de
onmiddellijke opnamesnelheid die
we zullen gebruiken  bespreek het in de punt 1.2
paragraaf 4.2 ook leuk om te
bespreken is optimaal foerageren Theorie suggereert een
functionele vorm voor allostatische controle
wil je van tevoren iets toevoegen
over optimaal foerageren
niemand anders dan ik wil Ik wil
met de auteurs praten  over wat betekent dat
zelfs,
dat zal geweldig zijn, goede vergelijking
acht
Global capture rate
sectie 4.3 feedback of feedforward
controle met generatieve actie Concepten
dus hier zijn wat meer formalismen en dit
is niet binnen het
kader van de experimentele psycholoog,
maar eerder het regeltheoretische
kader met  de allostatische capaciteitsschatter
in de linker
sectie 4.3
vergelijking 10 vergelijking 11.
meer variabelen
stoc  hastic SOC voor optimale controle die
eerder werd genoemd
vergelijking 12.
figuur 10. deze zal leuk zijn
om een ​​hiërarchisch generatief model te bespreken
dat meerdere tijdschalen en
referentieverdelingen op elk niveau vastlegt
zonder empirische vragen
over neurale hiërarchieën te behandelen. We gebruiken
een model met L gelijk aan  vier modellen die
overeenkomen met figuur zes
het definieert wat sommige van deze knooppunten betekenen,
maar de y-as vergroot de tijdschaal,
dus misschien langzamere dingen hogerop en
dan aan de rechterkant is het verstrijken van de tijd,
dus waar denk je aan
of wat is  als een manier waarop we
de interpretatie hiervan
goed kunnen benaderen, probeer ik geen slimme Apple te zijn,
maar ik vind het interessant dat L4
het je behoorlijk wat
informatie geeft die ik bedoel, er is
misschien en ze praten over de  feit
dat er meer dan vier niveaus zijn, maar
ze willen zich daarop concentreren voor mij. Ik
bedoel, waar mijn hersenen naartoe gaan is oké, dus
we hebben het water we hebben de gist
we hebben de hop we hebben  heb de granen en
dat kan een
behoorlijk product maken, dus je kunt voorbij gaan
dat je sap kunt toevoegen of wat dan ook, maar
je hebt de vier basisingrediënten dus
nu door de tijd gaan wat maakt dat
mogelijk, dus nogmaals, het zou leuk voor hen zijn
om dat uit elkaar te trekken, want ik
denk dat er zelfs hierin genoeg is
om
veel dingen
goed uit te zoeken 4.4 feedbackcontrole met
generatieve actie Concepten nog steeds is
er vergelijking 13 vergelijking 14. en dan een
mooi citaat lezers bekend met
voorspellende verwerking
en actief  gevolgtrekking zal de
vorm van de bovenstaande vergelijking herkennen 14.
als een negatieve vrije energie of een variatie
ondergrens Begrensd voor discussie zie enkele
citaten, aangezien doelstellingen doorgaans
op verschillende gelijkwaardige manieren kunnen worden uitgeschreven en geïnterpreteerd.
Elk daarvan
kan met zijn eigen intuïties komen. Er
zijn argumenten  voor de computationele en
thermodynamische efficiëntie van het minimaliseren van
deze specifieke divergentie in de loop
van neurale verwerking, maar tot op
heden  betrouwbaar bewijs sluit
andere, meer complexe informatieverschillen niet uit
voor het bestraffen van
feedbackcorrectie van bewegingen,
dus het is behoorlijk interessant hoe verschillende
ondergrenzen
variaties ondergrenzen negatieve vrije
energieën bestaan ​​alsof er
vrije energie is en dan is er vrije energie
van de verwachte toekomst en er is alles
van  deze varianten en dan kan elk van die
energieën anders worden ontleed,
zoals vergelijking 2.6 in het leerboek,
dus het is
interessant om te zien hoe ze ten eerste
convergeerden naar dit soort overvloed
en waarom het zo'n resonantie zou hebben
met het principe van vrije energie
en wat doet  dat betekent
en hoe kunnen verschillende verdelingen
van deze energiegrenzen ons helpen nadenken
over systemen die overleven.
van bekendheid en ik worstelde niet echt
met het soort
slotstap waar ze doorheen gingen,
maar  zodra we bij vergelijkingen 13 kwamen
en de sprong naar vergelijking 15 en 16.
iemand die slimmer is dan ik
zal die
sprong in heel eenvoudige bewoordingen moeten kunnen uitleggen, want
ook al heb ik het een aantal
keren gelezen  Ik weet nog steeds niet precies hoe het
werkt, dus nogmaals, de auteurs zullen echt
hun hun hun
hun zachtste handschoenen willen meenemen omdat ik mijn handheld nodig heb
ja overeengekomen
sectie 4.4 nog steeds hier is vergelijking 15.
sectie 4.4 hier is vergelijking 16.
het vergrote doel vervangen
fancy
J
vergelijking 14.
en de analytische uitdrukking voor de
optimale feedbackcontroller alleen
vergelijking 15 in de Bellman vergelijking
vergelijking 12 zou
vergelijking 16 opleveren. laten we eens kijken wat het is, ja,
nu is de hardnekkige recursieve term in
de vergelijking
Etc
een manier vinden om dit te vervangen  term zal
een meer rekenkundig hanteerbaar probleem opleveren
de informatie Divergentieterm in fancy
J biedt precies zo'n manier, omdat het kan
worden geschreven als precies
het verschil  tussen het hardnekkige
harde maximum onder Q star star sub Phi
en het meer handelbare gladde maximum
onder de vooraf geplande actie Concept in
symbolen vergelijking 17. best interessant
oke
um s vergelijking 17 tot en met 21
dan de laatste sectie sectie vijf
discussie
misschien kun je me helpen  vandaag zijn we dus 13
tot en met 17 en dan 18 19 en 20 een
manier om
enkele van de schaalvrije
formalismen samen te stellen met de schaalspecifieke of
schaalvriendelijke details in bijzonderheden als je
dit leest, is dat wat je ze zag  proberen te
verduidelijken
dat is een geweldige
vraag
en dus praat je over globaal
en ik denk dat ze dat moeten kunnen
spellen en ik denk ja, maar
nogmaals, ik ben
het was plotseling dat dingen
voor mij in de sloot gingen
dit is wat ik zou
wagen
in het eerste gedeelte,
er is een contrast tussen
homeostase en allostase
en over hoe beloningssystemen niet
langer nodig zijn onder bepaalde
gedistribueerde modellen van hersenneuro-anatomie
en een functie
dus ik geloof dat de volgende
formalismen de toegevoegde doelstelling vervangen
in een optimaliteits- en optimalisatiekader
zoals de Bellman-vergelijking die vaak wordt
gebruikt voor beloningsmaximalisatie, dus ik word
beloond door naar de top van de
berg te gaan,
dus ik ga paden evalueren op basis
op hoeveel beloning ze krijgen oke
en dan zal nieuwsgierigheid of
zo meer waardevol zijn in de tijd dat
Horizon dat ik dacht
dat het de beloning vergemakkelijkt in termen van
hoogte,
terwijl we hier de beweging
naar dat zien zoals Optimale
manoeuvreerbaarheidsmaximalisatie
met de pdfcdf-relatie
zoals in plaats van te proberen Divergentie te verminderen
tot het middelpunt van de CDF-
rechts, maximaliseer je je reactievermogen
in termen van het maximaliseren van de log-PDF, oké,
dus ik denk dat dat de augmented
um-beloningsfunctie is
die handelbaar is
en dan blijft er wat werk over om
die functie te specificeren en hoe het  gedraagt ​​zich
misschien
goed
dan sectie vijf discussie
onderschepping stabiliseert actie en
construeert al  verlorenatische referenties
mensen kunnen naar de citaten kijken alles
om hier samen te vatten
nee oke 5.1 de hersenen zien als een
allostatische optimale controller
het allostatische pad integrale controle
apic model in sectie 4 impliceert een
aantal specifieke hypothesen Naast die
generieke tot stochastische optimale controle is
er enige discussie  van gedeelde
modelleringskeuzes met actieve inferentiemodellen
misschien genoeg om apic als
een soort actief inferentiemodel te beschouwen
en dan een paar andere functies die
in strikte zin worden gedeeld met actieve inferentiemodellen
als die al bestaat
en ook gerelateerde modelleringsinspanningen
alles om nee toe te voegen
nee, ze spellen dat vrij duidelijk
hier, je wilt dit gewoon goed doorlezen
de 5.1 biedt enkele voorspellingen
en enkele contrasten met het apic-model
5.2
het lichaam en de hersenen door de lens
van de controletheorie
figuur zes laat zien hoe viscerale
zintuiggegevens opstijgen in effect  om X afferente
interceptieve voorspellingsfouten te worden
wil je uitleggen br  wat een
welvarende X betekent,
want mensen kunnen dat misschien
uitleggen in de woordenlijst, maar het is in
feite een duidelijk signaal op een
bedieningssignaal. Er is een beetje
recursie
daar wil je iets aan toevoegen.
is
afferent is geleidend of geleid
naar binnen of naar iets voor de
zenuwen het centrale zenuwstelsel voor
bloedvaten het orgaan levert goed
en eh
hoe zou je exacte inspanningen onderscheiden
alleen het is gewoon dat soort
cumulatief
het is niet het is niet een soort van de
eerste
is wat ik ervan afnam dat de
accumulatie van die schijnbare signalen
interessant is
Ik denk dat je het mis hebt dat is wat ik nam
vijf drie onderscheppings- en capaciteitscurven
theorieën van perifere voorspellende codering
reden dat de
metabolisch meest goedkope reacties van een neuron
de voorspelbare stimuli zouden moeten vertegenwoordigen,
terwijl dure  reacties zijn gereserveerd
voor de meest verrassende stimuli, een of
andere voorspelling  s en suggesties van
Barrett 2017
en bevindingen van dwerg in 2013 bepaalde
perifere interceptors en mensen
verminderen hun operante vuursnelheid tot nul
onder een constante stimulus,
dus dat is best interessant, zoals als er geen
verandering
is, vertel me er dan niet over en dat
zou goedkoop moeten zijn onder  een model waarin iets
minder vaak verandert dan niet
en er zijn nog meer
hypothesen die we hebben verondersteld dat een
toename van een dergelijk reactievermogen,
wat de noodzaak is in dit apic-model,
zou kunnen werken als beloningen
die gedragstrajecten positief versterken,
terwijl een afname van het
reactievermogen als kosten negatief zou kunnen werken  het versterken van
gedragstrajecten
zodat opties open blijven gedurende de
oneindige tijd Horizon wordt gelijk
aan het laten drijven van het bedrijf of
het begrensd houden van de fysiologie,
ja
buitenlandse
continuïteit in plaats van alleen maar het maximaliseren van de
hoeveelheid USD of
calorieën, maar eerder een verminderde of
begrensde verrassing over een bereik en een
traject en  een strategie
niet  in dit model zoals hier vermeld
om die
5.3 onderscheppings- en capaciteitscurves te genereren
meer
5.4 conclusies ten slotte keren we terug naar de
amateur-
trefbalspeler
de mier volwassen ja en
um enkele samenvattingen van het apic-model
en suggesties over de compatibiliteit ervan
met een referent-controlehypothese
en enkele van  de
traceerbaarheid is de discussie, dan appendix B
airconditioning
waar we het eerder over hebben gehad, maar het
is best een cool onderwerp, dus
om deze bijlagen gewoon over te slaan en
ze met de auteurs te bespreken, hopen we dan uh
wat meer vergelijkingen in vergelijking B
die het recept formuleren en
aërodische controle leidt tot het vrije energie
principe fep
meer van bijlage B bijlage C apic model
afleiding details
vergelijkingen
C 0.1.2 volledige afleiding van optimale waarde
functie en transitie Dynamics meer
vergelijkingen
de padintegraal vorm voor de waarde
wenselijkheid functie geeft zijn naam aan
de techniek  van padintegrale controle
enzovoort, een soort slotnota
we  vroeg zich af hoe dit verband houdt met de
Bayesiaanse mechanica
en met de
padformulering van de meest rechtse van de drie
gezichten van de Bayesiaanse mechanica
en over hoe mogelijk vanuit een
heel ander uitgangspunt
en met verschillende
benaderingen en beperkingen een
aantal vergelijkbare
kenmerken zijn ontstaan ​​en in apic zijn gemarkeerd
die ook worden gemarkeerd en relevant zijn
voor Bayesiaanse mechanica in de
padformalisatie en misschien is er
een soort niet-toegewezen Venn-diagram
daar en enkele overeenkomsten en
verschillen de
nabijheid van de laatste livestream,
per ongeluk of met opzet,
maakt de
um de manier waarop je ernaar kijkt  dit artikel is
interessant, ik zeg gewoon ja, ik ben
het goed eens met
alles waarmee je wilt
afsluiten.
Ik denk dat het idee om naar een mod te kunnen kijken
bij modellering en interne
modellering en een soort van coördinatie
daarvan, ofwel
weer een soort van minimaal twee  anders
als risicobeheersing of risicominimaliserende
oefening daarom een ​​beperkende strategie
of als optie gen  het ontwikkelen of
uitbreiden van een strategie zou iets
heel interessants zijn om met de auteurs over te praten,
want nogmaals, ik kan het niet ik
kan er niet echt achter komen of
het apic-model in beide domeinen werkt
totdat ik voorbij de sprong tussen
formalisme 13
en al ben  de weg omhoog naar 17 18 19 naar 20.
maar ik bedoel met een uitleg daarvan
en uh en een en een zachte por zou het
interessant zijn om uit te zoeken
hoe dat werkt als die dingen lijken te
zijn wij als fysiologische
entiteiten  kan jongleren met zowel het
risicobeheer als de opties optie
generator optie uitbreiden, dus ik ben daar
echt heel enthousiast over
vanaf een
hier is wat ik voel hoe moet ik dat
lezen in termen van wat ik kan hoe
ver kan ik mijn  volgende weddenschap
vanuit een allostatisch perspectief Ik denk
dat dat
echt spannend is als je, zoals ik al zei, als
ik
een beter idee kan krijgen van hoe die sprong werkt in
hun model
[Muziek]
ja zeker geïnteresseerd in die
oneindige tijd Horizon en die mentaliteit
van zoals
w  wat is de beste fysiologische
beslissing over de oneindige Horizon
wacht dat is een goede vraag en ja
de Eeuwige nu
de aanwezigheid
en dan um ook gewoon een beetje meer
alledaags zoals wat voor soort
gegevens relevant zijn voor dit type model
zijn het gegevens die al bestaan ​​voor
mensen,
is het iets waar je
veel uit een schaarse dataset kunt extrapoleren
of heb je een heleboel replicatie nodig
om goed statistisch vertrouwen te krijgen in de
modelparameter en bevindingen te extrapoleren
die als niet-triviale
um zijn
en waar wordt deze
technologie of benadering gebruikt  of
waar zou het kunnen worden gebruikt er zijn zo
veel dingen die interessant zijn
om over te
praten,
bedankt voor alle voorbereiding en
hulp bij deze Dean en tot ziens in de
punt één en verder oke mijn vriend
doe voorzichtig